Hey guys, it's Joel and this is a video about what to do if brain spotting does not work. I talk about brain spotting a whole lot. A lot of people are into it and then they come and try and get the brain spotting because they've seen some of the videos or content about trauma and the different approaches to treat trauma on our website. So just so you'll know, I'm only licensed to practice in Alabama and I'm in Birmingham, Alabama, which is a lot of drive from some places, even in Alabama, but I cannot see you if you're out of state. I don't see anyone via teletherapy and some therapists at Taproot do, Sarah Smith does, and christy wood does but i also i'm happy to talk to you i'm happy to uh point you in the right direction for where you can get uh resources to help trauma wherever
大家好，我是Joel，这期视频是关于如果大脑定位疗法（Brainspotting）不起作用该怎么办。我经常谈论大脑定位疗法。很多人对它很感兴趣，在看了我们网站上关于创伤以及治疗创伤的不同方法的视频或内容后，他们会来尝试这种疗法。首先要说明的是，我只在阿拉巴马州拥有执业许可，我在阿拉巴马州的伯明翰，这对某些地方的人来说路程很远，即使在阿拉巴马州内也是如此，但如果你在外州，我无法为你提供服务。我不通过远程治疗看诊，虽然Taproot的一些治疗师（如Sarah Smith和Christy Wood）提供这项服务，但我很乐意与你交谈，也很乐意为你指明方向，告诉你无论你在哪里，都可以从哪里获得帮助创伤的资源。
you are or tell you what to look for in a clinician or find people and i do that all the time but a lot of people call from out of state when they see these and they ask for how to get brain spotting i can't see a out of state unfortunately um but uh also a lot of people come and they the really the most common question that we get is i saw your resources brain spotting sounded super cool and i went to do brain spotting and when i did it didn't work or i wasn't sure if i was doing it right and the therapist is doing stuff that is not what you did. They're just kind of holding the pointer. And so I get that phone call a lot and I talk to people and I'm happy to do that. But I made a video so that maybe this will help therapists who are getting going with brain spotting
或者告诉你应该寻找什么样的临床医生，或者帮你找到合适的人。我经常这样做，但很多人在看到这些视频后从外州打来电话，询问如何进行大脑定位疗法。很遗憾，我无法为外州的人提供服务。此外，很多人来找我时，最常见的问题是：“我看了你的资源，觉得大脑定位疗法听起来很棒，但我去尝试了，结果却没用，或者我不确定自己做得对不对，而且治疗师做的事情和你做的不一样，他们只是拿着指针。”我经常接到这样的电话，我也很乐意与他们沟通。但我制作了这个视频，希望能帮助那些刚开始接触大脑定位疗法的治疗师。
have some new technique and approach and also or just a different perspective. And then also patients who are trying to figure out if brain spotting is right for them if it's being done right or if it's not a good fit or they need to talk to their therapist more so the big thing is like communicate with your therapist if you don't think something's working if you need more guidance you know whatever tell them I don't know if I'm doing this right so the big question is like am I doing brain spotting right? There's not a right way to do it. But the things that are going to interfere with the processes working is you thinking. So everyone does this, but you'll have these protective parts that pop up.
掌握一些新的技巧和方法，或者提供一个不同的视角。同时，也为了帮助那些正在判断大脑定位疗法是否适合自己、治疗是否正确、是否不匹配，或者是否需要与治疗师进行更多沟通的患者。最重要的一点是：如果你觉得某种方法不起作用，或者需要更多指导，一定要与你的治疗师沟通，告诉他们“我不确定我这样做对不对”。所以大问题是：“我做大脑定位疗法对吗？”其实并没有所谓的“正确”做法。但会干扰处理过程的事情是你“在思考”。每个人都会这样，但你会遇到一些突然出现的防御性部分。
I'm going to say like, you know, who, what is this? How does this work? Is this working? Am I doing it right? What is he thinking? All of that stuff. And everyone has those. Some people have more of them as a protective part that's going to rev up a whole lot more. And the thing that you want to do is not try and just like when you're meditating, the thing is to not kill them or try and get rid of them because then they'll overwhelm you and you can't. It's to notice it. Okay, I'm wondering what the therapist is thinking. And then come back to the body. Okay? Because the goal with brain spotting is to get into the mid and the subcortical brain. That's where the processing happens. And a lot of other therapy things too, this is relevant to other approaches that treat trauma. But to get there, you have to be feeling your body. It is
我会说，你知道，这是什么？这是怎么运作的？这有效吗？我做对了吗？他在想什么？所有这些想法。每个人都有这些念头。有些人会有更多的防御性部分，这些部分会变得非常活跃。你要做的不是试图消灭它们——就像冥想时一样，不要试图摆脱它们，因为那样它们会淹没你，你做不到。你要做的是注意到它们。比如，“我在想治疗师在想什么”，然后回到身体的感觉上。明白吗？因为大脑定位疗法的目标是进入大脑的中脑和皮层下区域。那是处理过程发生的地方。这与其他治疗创伤的方法也相关。但要到达那里，你必须感受你的身体。这是一种
a different kind of thinking. And it's why over time you get better at doing brain spawning because you're, you're just learning how to turn on that kind of felt intuitive sense that a lot of people, uh, are not good at because we have to give up our ego and a lot of our protective parts in order to get into that. Um, and so that's why you go deeper and deeper in successively. With brain spotting, a lot of times people are kind of scratching the surface for a little bit and the next session they go further in. And then you go really deep in and you maybe lose time and think that the 25 minutes you were under took five minutes or something.
不同类型的思考。这就是为什么随着时间的推移，你做大脑定位疗法会越来越好，因为你正在学习如何开启那种直觉感，很多人不擅长这一点，因为我们必须放弃自我和许多防御性部分才能进入那种状态。这就是为什么你会一次比一次深入。在大脑定位疗法中，很多时候人们起初只是触及表面，下一次治疗时会走得更深。然后你会进入非常深的状态，甚至会失去时间感，觉得你经历的25分钟处理过程只用了5分钟。
Those deeper processing moments are usually going to happen further on because you're learning, your brain is learning how to feel this way and it You know if you want to look at an MBTI there there are Myers-Briggs type tests There are certain kinds of things that most people who are gonna have a hard time not getting into their head with brain spotting They're gonna score very low on that part and then as they slowly do more brain spotting I've actually done this then you'll notice that you know thinking as something comes down my score is not way high there feeling and intuition usually go up usually a way to be more of a perceiver less of a judger is going to your score is going to change and you you're teaching your brain to think in a different way.
那些更深层的处理时刻通常会发生在后期，因为你的大脑正在学习如何感受这种状态。如果你想参考MBTI（迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标），大多数在进行大脑定位疗法时难以停止思考的人，在这一项上的得分会很低。但随着他们慢慢进行更多的大脑定位疗法，你会发现，随着思考减少，我的得分不再那么高，而感觉和直觉通常会上升。通常，变得更倾向于感知而不是判断，你的分数会发生变化，你正在教你的大脑以不同的方式思考。
So one of the things that people say when they come in is, hey, my therapist like held the pointer like this. And they were like, what do you feel here? What do you feel here? What do you feel here? And I was like, nothing, nothing, nothing. Or I don't know, my back kind of hurts. You know, there wasn't anything that was dramatic that was happening. And that's how they train you to do brain spawning in phase one.
所以人们来的时候常说：“嘿，我的治疗师拿着指针像这样，然后问我‘你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？’我回答说‘什么都没有，什么都没有，什么都没有’，或者‘我不知道，我的背有点疼’。”你知道，并没有发生什么戏剧性的事情。而这就是他们在第一阶段培训中教你如何做大脑定位疗法的方式。
When the people call and they say, like, hey, how do I go to do therapy with somebody who's doing this the way that you do and talk about it? I don't know. There are certain things I can look for. But the short answer is, like, probably nobody does unless you're one of the people who works for Taproot that has worked with me or is in supervision with me which you're welcome to do if you would like to I actually can do that out of state I can't legally supervise you in another state but I can do training online and I can also if you want one of the things we do is work with you for a couple years before you come to Taproot to help take you into private practice do do supervision with people. And that's a good way to learn trauma treatment. But when you have a therapist that's going like, you know, what do you feel here? What do you feel here? What do you feel here? And you're like, I don't know, I'm not
当人们打电话问：“嘿，我怎么才能找到像你这样操作并讨论它的人进行治疗？”我不知道。有一些我可以寻找的特征。但简短的回答是，可能没人会这样做，除非你是Taproot的员工，或者曾与我共事，或者正在接受我的督导——如果你愿意，欢迎这样做。我实际上可以在外州进行督导，虽然我在法律上不能在另一个州督导你，但我可以在线进行培训。如果你愿意，我们可以在你加入Taproot之前与你合作几年，帮助你进入私人执业领域，并为你提供督导。这是学习创伤治疗的好方法。但当你的治疗师问“你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？”而你回答“我不知道，我不”
sure what to do. And they're not really giving you a lot of guidance. And you're being like, am I doing it right? You know, whatever. And they're like, no, just keep feeling, just keep feeling. That is the way that they're trained in phase one. And I came to brain spawning a little bit differently. I was an EMDR clinician. So you're moving the eye during EMDR. I didn't agree with all of the EMDR scripting. So I had my own. And what I did is I had a trauma map and the trauma map was how we mapped, how does this trauma want to move you? You know, when you feel the bad feeling, what does your spine want to do? What do you notice in your body? You know, what are the protective parts that pop up in your
“确定该做什么”，而他们并没有给你很多指导。你心想：“我做对了吗？”等等。他们却说：“不，继续感受，继续感受。”这就是他们在第一阶段受到的训练方式。我接触大脑定位疗法的方式略有不同。我曾是一名EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）临床医生。在EMDR中，你需要移动眼睛。我并不完全同意EMDR的所有脚本，所以我有了自己的方法。我做的是一张“创伤地图”，这张地图记录了创伤如何想要驱动你。你知道，当你感到那种糟糕的感觉时，你的脊椎想做什么？你在身体里注意到了什么？你知道，那些出现在你的
thinking and cognition? How do your fingers want to move? Do you want to curl up into a ball and hide something? Do you want to just let go and sink into the carpet? Do you want to stand up and fight? You know, when I feel trapped, when I feel sad, when I feel whatever the feeling I can't feel is, what does it do to my body, how does it want me to move me? And I'd have people actually move and would do the EMDR. And while I was doing that, I started noticing that the pupil in the eye kind of jumped over a spot. Like people are trying to track my eye, you know, my finger with their eye.
思维和认知中的防御性部分是什么？你的手指想怎么动？你想蜷缩成一团躲起来吗？你想彻底放松并沉入地毯里吗？你想站起来反抗吗？你知道，当我感到被困住、感到悲伤，或者感到某种我无法感受的情绪时，它对我的身体有什么影响？它想让我如何移动？我会让人们真正动起来，并进行EMDR。在做这些的时候，我开始注意到瞳孔在某个点上跳动了一下。就像人们试图用眼睛追踪我的手指一样。
And then they would see like the pupil kind of like, whoop, jump over these spots where it didn't want to be unconsciously because, you know, it's moving quickly. People aren't doing that consciously. It's just an involuntary movement. And so I started moving my fingers to that spot while we're doing the trauma map. And then people would dissociate. They would go like way deep into processing. Cause I work with very complex trauma patients. And so patients liked this and they were requesting it and they were saying this works better than CBT or EMDR or whatever, but I didn't really know what I was doing. And some patients were experiencing like repressed memories, like things that parts of a traumatic event that they hadn't remembered before or different, you know, parts. And I noticed that the Z axis was really important too, like not just left and right,
然后他们会看到瞳孔像“嗖”地一下跳过了那些它潜意识里不想停留的点，因为移动很快。人们不是有意识地这样做，这只是不自主的运动。所以我开始在进行创伤地图时，把手指移到那个点上。然后人们就会解离。他们会进入非常深的处理状态。因为我处理的是非常复杂的创伤患者。所以患者喜欢这种方式，他们会要求这样做，并说这比CBT或EMDR等方法更有效。但我当时并不真正知道自己在做什么。有些患者经历了被压抑的记忆，比如他们以前没记住的创伤事件的部分，或者不同的部分。我注意到Z轴（深度）也非常重要，不仅仅是左右，
but how far or up and down, but how far back was I? You know, sometimes if I hit a spot, then I would just see the pupil explode. So I'm watching the pupil a lot more than the way that people are trained to do brain spawning in the training. I mean, they tell you to look for the dilation a little bit, but I'm really reading it more than I think most clinicians do based on what I'm hearing from people that have had it with other clinicians, including people in my family. So one of the things that like,
还有远近或上下，我离得有多远？你知道，有时如果我击中了一个点，我就会看到瞳孔放大。所以我观察瞳孔的时间比培训中教导的方式要多得多。我的意思是，他们确实让你观察瞳孔的扩张，但我认为我比大多数临床医生读得更深，这是基于我从那些接受过其他临床医生治疗的人（包括我的家人）那里听到的反馈。所以，
I think that the clinicians need to do more of if you're a clinician is like, look how the eye is dilating. Cause I had been a clinician for three months. I didn't know what I was doing and I was not doing EMDR anymore. And I kept paying for more EMDR supervisions to say like, Hey, people like this, I don't know what to do.
我认为如果你是一名临床医生，你需要做更多的事情，比如观察眼睛是如何扩张的。因为我当时做临床医生才三个月，我不知道自己在做什么，而且我不再做EMDR了。我不断支付更多的EMDR督导费用，说：“嘿，人们喜欢这个，但我不知道该怎么办。”
EMDR is incredibly manualized and scripted. So everybody kept telling me, Oh, you just do 15 movements and then you stop, Don't stop and do what you're doing. And I knew that it was working. People were asking for it. Somebody said, hey, that sounds like brain spotting. I Google it. I paid $400 to talk to David Grand for an hour, who's the inventor of brain spotting. David was great. And I felt like he was the first person who listened to me and understood what I was saying and was open to what I was noticing. And he told me, go do brain spotting and you're going to see what this feels like. And then I did that and I pivoted my whole practice towards it because I think it was
EMDR是非常手册化和脚本化的。所以每个人都一直告诉我：“哦，你只需要做15次移动，然后停下来，不要停下来做你正在做的事情。”但我知道它有效。人们在要求它。有人说：“嘿，那听起来像大脑定位疗法。”我谷歌了一下。我花了400美元和大脑定位疗法的发明者David Grand谈了一个小时。David很棒。我觉得他是第一个倾听我、理解我在说什么，并对我所注意到的事情持开放态度的人。他告诉我：“去学习大脑定位疗法，你会明白这种感觉是什么。”然后我照做了，并将我的整个执业方向转向了它，因为我认为它是
one of the most effective tools that's out there. But they don't necessarily train you to do it the way that I do it. So if you're stuck with your therapist or you are a therapist and you want new techniques, I mean, here's just stuff to consider. So first off, EMDR is very restrictive. A lot of brain spawning clinicians were previously EMDR clinicians. And so there's a ton of rules. You do this amount of movement, then you go back, then you stop. Well, what if the person has dissociative identity disorder and they bark like a dog? Well, what if the person is crying in a puddle? Oh, well, you either stop it and you wait or you just go back and you do the movement. There's no way to insert yourself as a clinician. I mean, a limited amount there is, but the people who are certified in it, they're very like tight
目前最有效的工具之一。但他们不一定教你按照我的方式去做。所以如果你被你的治疗师困住了，或者你是一名想要学习新技术的治疗师，这里有一些值得考虑的事情。首先，EMDR非常受限。许多大脑定位疗法的临床医生以前是EMDR临床医生。所以有很多规则：做多少次移动，然后回去，然后停下。好吧，如果那个人患有解离性身份障碍，并且像狗一样叫呢？好吧，如果那个人哭成一团呢？哦，好吧，你要么停下来等待，要么就回去做移动。作为临床医生，你没有办法介入。我的意思是，只有有限的余地，但那些获得认证的人，他们非常死板，
and very inflexible and it's very manualized. And so David Grand was also an ex EMDR clinician. I don't know, but I think my guess would be that brain spotting is kind of like way open-ended and open to the patient's experience, kind of as a reaction to the way that EMDR is. And I don't think that's bad, but I also have a different perspective than I think a lot of the EMDR people, the brain spotting trained people have, and that's fine. I don't think they're wrong. This is just a different take. I think that when they train clinicians to be so open to absolutely anything happening, sometimes you leave patients without enough information to go into processing. And also,
非常不灵活，而且非常手册化。所以David Grand也是一名前EMDR临床医生。我不知道，但我的猜测是，大脑定位疗法之所以如此开放，并对患者的体验持开放态度，某种程度上是对EMDR方式的一种反弹。我不认为这有什么不好，但我确实有与许多EMDR背景的大脑定位疗法培训者不同的视角，这没关系。我不认为他们错了。这只是不同的看法。我认为，当他们训练临床医生对任何可能发生的事情都保持如此开放时，有时你会让患者在没有足够信息的情况下进入处理过程。而且，
sometimes you don't give patients enough information to know what is going to maybe come up during processing. And David's whole thing is that like, if you're trapping people within this conception and you're being too analytical and you're trying to help them understand it, you're stopping processing from happening. I absolutely agree with that. That is true, right? But what happens is that sometimes what people take away from the training is that all they have to do is say, what do you feel here? What do you feel here? What do you feel here what do you feel here what do you feel here move the pointer around not look at the patient's eye you know and not look at what the patient's doing not give the patient a prompt and I just don't think
有时你没有给患者足够的信息，让他们知道在处理过程中可能会出现什么。David的整个观点是，如果你把人们困在这种概念中，并且你过于分析，试图帮助他们理解它，你就会阻止处理过程的发生。我完全同意这一点。这是真的，对吧？但问题是，有时人们从培训中学到的是，他们所要做的就是说：“你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？”然后移动指针，不看患者的眼睛，不看患者在做什么，不给患者任何提示。我只是不认为
that works there's an idea with brain spawning called staying in the tail of the comet and the training they will repeat that to you over and over again as a clinician and what they're saying is that you're not supposed to be in front of the patient trying to conceptualize the experience and get in front of their experience and help them into it. You're supposed to just let the experience happen, and you are in the tail of the comet. You're behind that, okay? And you're just waiting for it to come up and seeing if it comes up. And that's true.
那样有效。在大脑定位疗法中有一个概念叫“留在彗星的尾巴上”。在培训中，他们会作为临床医生一遍又一遍地向你重复这一点。他们的意思是，你不应该站在患者面前试图概念化这种体验，试图走在他们的体验前面并帮助他们进入。你应该只是让体验发生，而你是在彗星的尾巴上。你在它后面，明白吗？你只是在等待它出现，看看它是否会出现。这是对的。
When a patient is processing, you need to be quiet. You need to watch. Even if you have the most brilliant conception in the world, you don't need to talk. But if your client is not processing, you're not in the tail of the comet, man. Like you're watching the comet from earth. That's not being in the tail of the comet. And that's what a lot of clinicians do is they just keep waiting for processing to happen. And you do have to push people into it. There are people who I absolutely could not have helped if I did not break the training or you know deviate from what they tell you in those trainings and one of the things that I
当患者正在处理时，你需要保持安静。你需要观察。即使你拥有世界上最天才的概念，你也不需要说话。但如果你的客户没有在处理，你就不是在彗星的尾巴上，伙计。你就像是在地球上观察彗星。那不是在彗星的尾巴上。这就是很多临床医生所做的，他们只是不停地等待处理过程发生。你确实必须推动人们进入它。有些人如果我不打破培训规则，或者不偏离他们在那些培训中告诉你的内容，我绝对无法帮助他们。我做的其中一件事，
do that a lot of clinicians don't is that I move the pointer. I mean what they will tell you in brain spawning training is that you find the spawn in the person's eye if you're doing outside window where the clinician is looking for where they see the blinks and the dilation and the involuntary muscle movement and they wait there. So a lot of therapists they just are like, oh do you feel anything here? Even though they see something and the patient says no and then they just move. Okay, well everybody's different, right? You want to be in the tail of the comet and that means that not everyone is gonna have the ability to feel what is happening in their body right away. I mean one, this is a weirder treatment.
很多临床医生都不做，那就是我移动指针。我的意思是，在大脑定位疗法培训中，他们会告诉你，如果你在做“外窗”（outside window），即临床医生寻找他们看到眨眼、扩张和不自主肌肉运动的地方，你要在那里等待。所以很多治疗师只是说：“哦，你这里感觉到了什么？”即使他们看到了什么，而患者说没有，然后他们就移动了。好吧，每个人都不同，对吧？你想留在彗星的尾巴上，这意味着并不是每个人都能立刻感觉到身体里正在发生什么。我的意思是，首先，这是一种更奇怪的治疗方法。
They may just not think that it works. So like, I will tell people, hey, just hang out here a minute. You know, we're going to wait here. I know you're saying you don't feel anything, but I see their face getting tight. I see their eye dilating. I know that this is a brain spot. I am the one who does this all the time. I'm not an expert. You know, I'm not the expert in taking away autonomy from you, but I know that you're going to go into processing here because that's how people work I'm being open to your experience and your experience is that you cannot feel your experience right now and so I'll hang out in a spot for a minute and I'll tell the person to wait and they'll keep saying they don't feel anything and then what they'll do a lot of the time is they'll start moving their head so I say look at the pointer
他们可能只是不认为它有效。所以，我会告诉人们：“嘿，在这里待一会儿。你知道，我们要在这里等一下。我知道你说你什么都没感觉到，但我看到你的脸变紧了。我看到你的眼睛在扩张。我知道这是一个大脑定位点。我是那个经常这样做的人。我不是专家。你知道，我不是那种剥夺你自主权的专家，但我知道你在这里会进入处理状态，因为人们就是这样运作的。我对你的体验持开放态度，而你的体验是你现在无法感觉到你的体验，所以我会在一个点上停留一会儿，我会告诉那个人等待。他们会一直说他们什么都没感觉到，然后他们很多时候会做的是，他们会开始移动头部。”所以我说：“看着指针，
which is the eye position and then they move their head because they'll scratch or they'll get fidgety and they're getting restless because I'm seeing the brain spot work the the fight or flight spot the fight or flight system is activating people are getting fidgety but because they move their head now they're not on that spot anymore and the brain spotting training will tell you not to move the pointer in phase one and phase two i don't do that if you moved your head you're in a different spot now and i'm going to keep chasing you to it and hitting that spot where I see the dilation. Even if you go and move over here, then I'm going to move the pointer to the left. If you move your head to the left, I'm going to find it again, and I'm going to keep doing that until you start
也就是眼睛的位置。”然后他们移动了头部，因为他们会抓痒或者变得坐立不安，他们变得焦躁是因为我看到大脑定位点在起作用。战斗或逃跑系统正在激活，人们变得焦躁不安，但因为他们移动了头部，他们现在不在那个点上了。大脑定位疗法的培训会告诉你，在第一阶段和第二阶段不要移动指针。我不这样做。如果你移动了头部，你现在就在一个不同的点上了，我会一直追着你，击中那个我看到扩张的点。即使你移动到这里，我也会把指针移到左边。如果你把头移到左边，我会再次找到它，我会一直这样做，直到你开始
processing. If you are resistant, if you have a lot of resistance to this, maybe you don't believe it. I'm going to help you feel it so that you can feel that this works and have a little bit more faith in the process. And if you're just moving the pointer and saying, what do you feel here? What do you feel here? What do you feel here? For 10 sessions, you are not giving people reason to have faith in the process because you're not giving them any experience with processing. So like, yeah, they're not going to think it works. I think that you have to push people a little harder than a lot of the trainings say. So I moved the pointer left and right up and down based on how the person moved their head. And sometimes people move their head like, you know, really far to the left because they're trying to get away from me. And we're
处理。如果你有抵触情绪，如果你对此有很多抵触，也许你不相信它。我会帮你感受到它，这样你就能感觉到这是有效的，并对这个过程多一点信心。如果你只是移动指针并说：“你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？”持续10次治疗，你并没有给人们理由去相信这个过程，因为你没有给他们任何处理的经验。所以，是的，他们不会认为它有效。我认为你必须比许多培训所说的稍微用力一点。所以我根据人移动头部的方式，将指针左右上下移动。有时人们会把头移得，你知道，非常靠左，因为他们试图躲避我。我们正在
looking at the back room and their perception is that I'm moving the pointer. They're like, well, you were wanting me to turn that way. And I'm like, no, I'm only moving it when you turn your head. Do you see how when I hit this, you want to move? And now I'm bringing that into awareness a little bit. And they're like, oh, wow. Yeah, OK. And there's more buy-in from the patient. And they're a little bit more aware of what's happening when we're going.
看着后台，他们的感知是我在移动指针。他们会说：“好吧，你是想让我转向那边。”我说：“不，我只有在你转头时才移动它。你看到了吗？当我击中这个点时，你想移动？现在我正在把这一点带入意识中。”他们会说：“哦，哇。是的，好的。”患者的参与度更高了。而且当我们进行时，他们对正在发生的事情也更了解了。
So I think that's important. I also move the pointer on what's called the Z-axis. I move it towards their face and away from their face. And you'll notice that there's individual spots on that axis, right? So like maybe I pass over this spot that's about a foot from the face and I get a little bit of blinking or I see dilation. Well, then I pass by it a couple more times because I want to see, is that just, you know, like, is that just something that came up out of nowhere or is that a real part of the spot? And when I see the blink in the same spot a lot of times on that Z axis, I creep up to the spot. And that usually pushes people a little bit deeper into
所以我认为这很重要。我还在所谓的Z轴上移动指针。我把它移向他们的脸，又移开。你会注意到在该轴上有单独的点，对吧？所以，也许我经过这个离脸大约一英尺的点，我得到了一点眨眼，或者我看到了扩张。好吧，然后我再经过它几次，因为我想看看，这只是，你知道，这只是凭空出现的东西，还是这个点真正的一部分？当我多次在Z轴上的同一个点看到眨眼时，我会慢慢靠近那个点。这通常会把人们推得更深一点，进入
processing. That's helpful. That's another way. So, you know, if you're a therapist, I would do that. Or if you're a patient who's moving your head in therapy, I would, you know, be aware of that. Another thing that the phase two clinicians have learned if they've taken phase two of brain spawning is there's these glasses that you can wear. One covers the left eye, one covers the right eye. And there's something in brain spotting called, and the words are different. I think like in Britain, they call them trigger spots or something. The way I learned, which I mean, or like anxiety spots, like people have different language.
处理过程。这很有帮助。这是另一种方法。所以，你知道，如果你是一名治疗师，我会这样做。或者如果你是一名在治疗中移动头部的患者，我会，你知道，意识到这一点。第二阶段的临床医生如果参加过大脑定位疗法的第二阶段培训，他们学到的另一件事是，有一种你可以戴的眼镜。一只覆盖左眼，一只覆盖右眼。在大脑定位疗法中有一种东西，词汇不同。我想在英国，他们称之为“触发点”（trigger spots）之类的。我学习的方式，我的意思是，或者像“焦虑点”（anxiety spots），人们有不同的语言。
But the way that I learned and the way what most of the training say is there's activation spots and resource spots. The activation spots turn anxiety up, they help you process the trauma. The resource spots kind of bleed anxiety off and help you calm down and regulate and soothe. There's also an activation eye that speeds processing up and makes it more intense. And there is also a resource eye that slows processing down
但我学习的方式，以及大多数培训所说的是，有“激活点”（activation spots）和“资源点”（resource spots）。激活点会增加焦虑，它们帮助你处理创伤。资源点会排出焦虑，帮助你冷静下来，调节和安抚。还有一个“激活眼”（activation eye），它会加速处理过程并使其更强烈。还有一个“资源眼”（resource eye），它会减慢处理过程，
and makes you calmer. So if you go on the resource eye to a resource spot as a clinician, you're really going to calm that person down. So one of the things that I noticed, because I'm looking for dilation more than they teach you, is that when I know I'm on a brain spot, when I see it, and that spot is, I call it like a wibble, it really wants to open. It's like the lens of the camera is trying to dilate open, but then I see it getting pinched shut. You know, it's like, well, no.
让你更平静。所以如果你作为临床医生在资源眼上使用资源点，你真的会让人平静下来。所以我注意到的其中一件事，因为我比他们教你的更关注扩张，是当我确定我在一个大脑定位点上时，当我看到它时，那个点是，我称之为“晃动”（wibble），它真的想打开。就像相机的镜头试图扩张打开，但我看到它被挤压关闭了。你知道，就像，好吧，不。
What's happening in their head, because I know that. I've recorded my eye doing this. I have that video up, and I've seen what my eye is doing when I'm feeling it. And same thing with the patients. What's happening is that they're thinking. You're starting to feel yourself go into a scary place, and then the patient's like, hell no, I'm not going to go there. is that they're thinking you're starting to feel yourself go into a scary place and then the patient's like hell no i'm not going to go there and then they're thinking so you're watching somebody being pulled back up into thought and when you have when you start to say hey i'm seeing a spot here but i'm noticing that you're right on the edge you go into
他们的脑子里发生了什么，因为我知道这一点。我录下过我的眼睛做这个动作。我有那个视频，我看到了我在感受它时我的眼睛在做什么。患者也是一样。发生的事情是他们在思考。你开始感觉到自己进入了一个可怕的地方，然后患者心想：“去你的，我才不要去那里。”然后他们在思考。所以你正在看着某人被拉回到思想中。当你开始说：“嘿，我在这里看到了一个点，但我注意到你就在边缘，你进入了
the processing you're kind of feeling something scary that maybe you know it doesn't really fit into words but you're kind of feeling a scary thing or need to move like you don't like this position and then you're thinking about something. What is that? And then they're like, oh my God, because like you just read their mind. There's more buy-in to the process. You're not conceptualizing it and telling them what to think. You're making room for their experience in a way that just being like, what do you feel here? What do you feel here? What do you feel here? It does not make room for, um, because they're going to trust you and they're going to have faith in this process. in this process and you know that it works this way
处理过程，你正在感觉到一些可怕的事情，也许你知道，它并不真正适合用语言表达，但你正在感觉到一件可怕的事情，或者需要移动，就像你不喜欢这个位置，然后你在想某件事。那是什么？”然后他们会说：“哦，天哪。”因为你就像读懂了他们的心思。对这个过程的参与度更高了。你不是在概念化它并告诉他们该想什么。你是在为他们的体验腾出空间，这种方式比仅仅问“你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？你这里感觉到了什么？”要好得多，因为他们会信任你，他们会对这个过程有信心。在这个过程中，你知道它是这样运作的，
so you can help them do that. A lot of clinicians don't. So then you can tell them, notice the thought, or if you're a patient, you can just do this. Notice the thought, it's a protective part. It's trying to protect you from this scary place that I'm trying to pull you into. It's like we're running on a treadmill
所以你可以帮助他们做到这一点。很多临床医生不这样做。所以你可以告诉他们：“注意到那个想法。”或者如果你是患者，你可以直接这样做。注意到那个想法，它是一个防御性部分。它试图保护你免受我试图把你拉进去的那个可怕地方的伤害。这就像我们在跑步机上跑步，
and eventually you're just gonna get too tired to run anymore and the treadmill's to pull you into. It's like we're running on a treadmill and eventually you're just going to get too tired to run anymore and the treadmill is going to pull you down there. But it's going to take a little while. But if a thought pops up, notice it, come back to the body. Because the deepest part of the emotion is the physical response in your body. So feel the emotion and then find where it is physically. And it's okay for this to move. We may start off thinking about your heart and your heart's the black hole and it's sucking. And then that pops open, and now my back is tight. Well, don't make patients think,
最终你会因为太累而跑不动了，跑步机会把你拉下去。但这需要一点时间。但如果一个想法出现了，注意到它，回到身体。因为情绪最深的部分是身体的生理反应。所以感受情绪，然后找到它在身体里的位置。这个位置移动也没关系。我们可能一开始在想你的心脏，心脏是黑洞，它在吸入。然后那个点打开了，现在我的背部很紧。好吧，不要让患者认为，
well, you have to just be thinking about your heart the whole time. Notice your whole experience and what's happening. That now notices it's in your neck. So when a patient is processing, be quiet and let them go. But if they're not, you haven't really done your job yet as a clinician and this you know Maybe is a little bit pushy or has a different perspective than some of the training and I don't think that I'm totally right Or this works for everybody, but if you're bumping into this problem, these are some ways around it One thing is that you notice body responses and brain spotting and so a lot of times people aren't even aware that like I'm jerking
“你必须一直想着你的心脏。”注意到你的整个体验以及正在发生的事情。现在注意到它在你的脖子里。所以当患者正在处理时，保持安静，让他们去。但如果他们没有，作为临床医生你还没有真正完成你的工作。这，你知道，也许有点强硬，或者与某些培训有不同的视角。我不认为我是完全正确的，或者这适用于每个人，但如果你遇到了这个问题，这些是一些解决方法。其中一件事是，你注意到大脑定位疗法中的身体反应，所以很多时候人们甚至没有意识到，比如我在抽动
My knee or I'm moving my hand and if they come out of processing and you're trying to get them to go back into it by being aware of the body, you know, if they're out of it, you can talk. If they're in it, let them go. But if they're coming out of it and they're not really there, I'll say, you know, notice your hand, notice your foot. And a lot of times they're like, oh, I'm not moving that. And then they realize that it's tight or something. And you see the eye open back up and they go back in. So you can't always see what's happening, though. Some people are way out of touch with their body. And some people have like muscle tension in their back where you see their backs locking up.
我的膝盖，或者我在移动我的手。如果他们从处理过程中出来，而你正试图通过意识到身体来让他们回到处理中，你知道，如果他们出来了，你可以说话。如果他们在处理中，让他们去。但如果他们正在出来，而他们并没有真正进入状态，我会说：“你知道，注意到你的手，注意到你的脚。”很多时候他们会说：“哦，我没在动那个。”然后他们意识到它很紧或者其他什么。你看到眼睛重新睁开，他们又回去了。不过，你并不总能看到正在发生的事情。有些人与身体的联系非常疏远。有些人背部有肌肉紧张，你会看到他们的背部锁住了。
But you can't really touch the patient. You know, if they're saying like, I don't feel anything, I don't feel anything. You can't just like dig in behind their clothes and say, look, OK, Your back's tight right here, right? Like that isn't our role as a therapist But there's people who I work with that help the process a lot with brain spawning They don't work at Tenebrute, but we refer to them Some people do something called myofascial release and some people do something called Rolf massage. R-O-L-F R-O-L-F F Rolf. And those are, those are neat. Um, there are kinds of massage that are not like, Oh, this place is sore. I'm going to rub on it. It's not structural as in like, Oh,
但你不能真的触碰患者。你知道，如果他们说：“我什么都没感觉到，我什么都没感觉到。”你不能直接挖进他们的衣服下面说：“看，好吧，你的背部这里很紧，对吧？”那不是我们作为治疗师的角色。但有些人我与之合作，他们在大脑定位疗法中对过程有很大帮助。他们不在Taproot工作，但我们推荐他们。有些人做一种叫“肌筋膜释放”（myofascial release）的东西，有些人做一种叫“罗尔夫按摩”（Rolf massage）。R-O-L-F，罗尔夫。那些，那些很棒。嗯，它们是某种按摩，不像“哦，这个地方酸痛，我要揉一下”。它不是结构性的，比如“哦，
your cartilage in your leg is weak, move this exercise and it'll go back. Most of these people are physical therapists. And, um, so they're doing a different thing than normal PT, but it's less structural. Um, but myofas myofascial release, and I'm not a massage therapist, so I'm quoting them. I don't have the expert on. We don't have the expert. One day I want to have them on the podcast and I'd like for them to speak for themselves, but we haven't been able to have time because we're so busy. So these myofascial and these Rolf massage people, they can really help bring stuff into awareness that you're just not going to be able to notice or get out of patients if they're overwhelmed. Now, when people say like, I don't
你腿上的软骨很弱，做这个练习它就会恢复”。这些人大多数是物理治疗师。所以他们做的事情与普通的物理治疗不同，但它不那么结构化。嗯，但是肌筋膜释放——我不是按摩治疗师，所以我是在引用他们的话。我没有专家在场。我们没有专家。有一天我想请他们上播客，我想让他们自己说，但我们因为太忙一直没能抽出时间。所以这些肌筋膜和罗尔夫按摩的人，他们真的可以帮助把东西带入意识，如果你不这样做，或者如果患者被淹没了，你是无法注意到或从患者身上挖掘出来的。现在，当人们说“我什么都没”
feel anything there, a lot of times what they mean is I'm feeling too much. I don't know what it is. I don't know how to label this stuff. I don't know how to feel it. It's not that you're not feeling, it's that you're overwhelmed. And the Rolf and myofascial people, which I hope work more with therapists in the future, because it's, we need to be more integrative. They're able to say things like, hey, it feels like your posture is trying to curl up into a ball and, and kind of like disappear. But at the same time, you want to like stand up and be heard and seen and be loud, but you're, you're this muscle's tight and that muscle's tight and they're pulling in different things and it's making pain here. You know,
“感觉到那里”时，很多时候他们的意思是“我感觉到了太多”。我不知道那是什么。我不知道如何给这些东西贴标签。我不知道如何感受它。不是你没在感受，而是你被淹没了。而罗尔夫和肌筋膜的人——我希望未来他们能与治疗师更多地合作，因为我们需要更具整合性——他们能够说出这样的话：“嘿，感觉你的姿势正试图蜷缩成一团，然后，有点像消失。但与此同时，你想要站起来，被听到、被看到，变得大声，但你，你的这块肌肉很紧，那块肌肉很紧，它们在拉扯不同的东西，这导致了这里的疼痛。”你知道，
I don't know all that stuff. I'm getting better at understanding how posture informs this because I work with them and the patients tell me what they say. And I have an ROI to talk to the provider and the provider has an ROI to talk to me. But, you know, like those things really help brain spotting. They help you get unstuck or give you some tools to go deeper into it. You know, I had a patient who she, I felt like I was seeing anger, but she couldn't get there. And the provider said, well, you've got a response where you want to fight, but then you also want to give up. So there's a, and then, you know, the eye just exploded. She went right into the processing. It really dilated. And like, we got some good work done. So that's like another thing
我不知道所有这些。我正在变得越来越擅长理解姿势如何影响这一点，因为我与他们合作，患者会告诉我他们说了什么。我有一份ROI（信息发布授权书）与提供者交谈，提供者也有一份ROI与我交谈。但是，你知道，这些事情真的有助于大脑定位疗法。它们帮助你摆脱困境，或者给你一些工具去更深入地挖掘。你知道，我有一个患者，我觉得我看到了愤怒，但她无法到达那里。提供者说：“好吧，你有一个反应，你想反抗，但你同时也想放弃。”所以有一个，然后，你知道，眼睛直接爆炸了。她直接进入了处理过程。它真的扩张了。而且，我们完成了一些很好的工作。所以那是另一件事，
that you can bring into it. If you're having a hard time getting stuck with the stuff. I think the trauma mapping, I talk about that a lot on here. I'm not going to go through it. More people should do that when they're having a hard time pushing the patient into the feeling. The brain spawning thing, again, it's kind of too open. They're like, what do you want to work on? They don't even say a lot of times like where is that in your body? Find that feeling.
你可以把它带入其中。如果你在处理这些东西时感到困难，被困住了。我认为创伤映射，我在这里经常谈论它。我不会再讲一遍了。当人们在推动患者进入感觉时遇到困难时，更多的人应该这样做。大脑定位疗法，再说一次，它有点太开放了。他们会说：“你想处理什么？”他们甚至很多时候不说“那在你的身体里哪里？找到那种感觉。”
You know, if somebody knows exactly what they want to work on, they go into processing, fine. Stay in the tail of the comment, right? But if you want to really help someone and they're coming in 10 times and they haven't processed anything, you need to kind of start bringing this into awareness to help them feel it to find the brain spot. I do something called tapping. I get something cold, like a rock or uh not pretty rock not like a dirty one there's uh crystals and a little brass column different things but i tell the person to concentrate on where it hurts or where they think feel the thing in their body and just tap it and
你知道，如果某人确切地知道他们想处理什么，他们进入处理过程，很好。留在彗星的尾巴上，对吧？但如果你想真正帮助某人，而他们来了10次，却什么都没处理，你需要开始把这一点带入意识，帮助他们感受到它，从而找到大脑定位点。我做一种叫“敲击”（tapping）的东西。我拿一些冷的东西，比如一块石头，或者，嗯，不是漂亮的石头，不是那种脏的，有水晶，还有小黄铜柱，不同的东西。但我告诉那个人集中注意力在它痛的地方，或者他们认为在身体里感觉到那个东西的地方，然后敲击它，
you and you'll see their eye kind of dart to the spot when they tap it because their body's associating with that thing brain spotting's is built, I think, on the body-brain associates this eye position with this past experience that's kind of stuck and undealt with. And you can also do gaze spotting that they teach you to do in phase two, where people are looking in the room when they're talking about, every single time I feel trapped and my dad does this, where is their eye going? If it's going to the same spot and there's nothing there in your room, then notice that and maybe just start there and trust yourself as a clinician, even if the patient's saying for the first couple minutes, I don't feel anything here. If you're seeing movement, go with it and help them process stuff.
你会看到他们的眼睛在敲击时会射向那个点，因为他们的身体正在与那个东西建立联系。大脑定位疗法是建立在身体-大脑将这个眼位与这个过去被困住且未处理的经历联系起来的基础上的。你也可以做第二阶段教你的“凝视定位”（gaze spotting），人们在谈论“每次我感到被困住，我爸爸就这样做”时，他们的眼睛在看哪里？如果它每次都看向同一个点，而你的房间里什么都没有，那么注意到这一点，也许就从那里开始，并作为临床医生相信你自己，即使患者在前几分钟说“我在这里什么都没感觉到”。如果你看到了移动，顺着它走，帮助他们处理事情。
Don't just wait for them to do everything. That's also not being in the tail of the comet. If you're just assuming that if you ask, well, what do you feel? What do you feel? Then eventually, or feel, feel, just feel. Eventually, they're just going to go into processing and your job is just to do that it's not your job is to do more than that we talked about like when people are thinking too much and they they can't get out of their head and that's one of the reasons why i think what clinicians need to do more of is look at what the eye is actually doing because you kind of intuitively learn to know if somebody's processing or not sometimes if the person's iris is real dark, it's very hard to see the difference in the black and the dark brown. You know,
不要只是等着他们做所有事情。那也不是在彗星的尾巴上。如果你只是假设如果你问“好吧，你感觉到了什么？你感觉到了什么？”然后最终，或者“感受，感受，只是感受”。最终，他们就会进入处理过程，你的工作就是做那个——不，你的工作是做更多的事情。我们谈到了当人们想得太多，他们无法从脑子里出来时，这就是为什么我认为临床医生需要做更多的事情是观察眼睛实际上在做什么，因为你某种程度上直觉地学会了知道某人是否在处理。有时如果人的虹膜非常深，很难看出黑色和深棕色的区别。你知道，
somebody with blue eyes, it's a lot easier to see that or somebody with, you know, light green eyes or something. But you can still see, I mean, especially with some of these, when somebody's pretty deep in processing, I mean, the iris is very active. The pupil is doing like weird things. I mean, sometimes like stuff you don't see unless somebody has like a concussion or something. I mean, I've had severe dissociative disorder patients have their pupil look like a strobe light. I mean, it's going from like, you know, an F-16 dilation on a camera to like an F-1, like huge. So I think it's important to read that. And, you know, I'd said before, like that when the pupil is like starting to open you know every time you hit that spot you're
对于蓝眼睛的人，或者浅绿色眼睛的人，这要容易观察得多。但你仍然可以看到，尤其是当某人处于深度处理状态时，虹膜是非常活跃的。瞳孔会做出一些奇怪的反应。有时，除非某人有脑震荡之类的症状，否则你是看不到这些反应的。我曾见过严重的解离性障碍患者，他们的瞳孔看起来就像频闪灯一样。我的意思是，它从相机上的F-16光圈大小变成了F-1，变得非常大。所以我认为解读这些信号很重要。而且，正如我之前所说，当瞳孔开始放大时，你知道每次你触及那个点时，你
seeing it start to bloom but it's not going into processing it's kind of pinching back off and then the person doesn't look like they're kind of feeling anything uh profound or anything that is like you know when people go into their body there's kind of a a dreamlike face or like a look of awe or, you know, you see muscles twitch or there's a look of discomfort. You know, you're seeing a spot, but nothing is happening. A lot of times, you know, they're thinking. And so talking about the thoughts that are coming up, learning to map those is helpful, but sometimes they're just not ever going to be able to think their way out of that or it's going to take a long time to think through it. And so in the phase
看到它开始绽放，但它并没有进入处理状态，而是又缩了回去，然后那个人看起来并没有感受到任何深刻的东西，或者说，你知道，当人们进入自己的身体时，会有一种梦幻般的表情，或者一种敬畏的神情，或者你会看到肌肉抽搐，或者表现出不适。你知道，你看到了一个点，但什么也没发生。很多时候，他们只是在思考。所以，谈论出现的想法并学习如何梳理这些想法是有帮助的，但有时他们可能永远无法通过思考来解决问题，或者需要很长时间才能想通。因此，在第二阶段
two brain spotting training they teach you to use the glasses to use an activation eye to speed things up or a resource eye to slow things down and so if you use a resource eye so you find the eye that makes you calmer and then you use the resource spot you're gonna pull a ton of anxiety off so if you've found like an activation spot where you need to process that trauma, but you can't get into it, or it's just taking multiple sessions,
脑点定位（Brainspotting）培训中，他们教你使用眼镜，利用激活眼来加速进程，或者利用资源眼来减缓进程。如果你使用资源眼，找到让你感到平静的那只眼睛，然后使用资源点，你就能消除大量的焦虑。所以，如果你找到了一个需要处理创伤的激活点，但你无法进入状态，或者这需要多次疗程，
sometimes brain spotting works better over like two hours, three hours, honestly, for certain kinds of people, you know, you wanna be open to how they're coming in. But unfortunately, insurance doesn't make a ton of sense, at least in Alabama, most states, they will pay for one session a day, but you can come seven days a week. You know, we're really, you know, two hours a week all at once is probably going to save them more money and get people better. Most people don't want that other hour to be private pay. So, you know, this is a way to kind of open that up faster without just waiting.
有时脑点定位在两到三个小时的疗程中效果更好，老实说，对于某些人来说，你需要对他们进入状态的方式保持开放态度。但不幸的是，保险公司并不太理解这一点，至少在阿拉巴马州和大多数州，他们只支付每天一次的疗程费用，但你可以每周来七天。你知道，我们真的认为，每周一次两小时的疗程可能会为他们节省更多钱，并让人们好起来。大多数人不想为额外的一小时支付私费。所以，这是一种在不等待的情况下更快打开局面的方法。
Bleed all the anxiety off with the resource side and the resource spot if somebody's having trouble thinking or calming down. And then you go to the activation eye, you know, and then you go to the activation spot and you try and go in that way. And now I'm able to process because my thoughts are not roiling of like, what is this? Why am I here? Does this work? Do I look stupid? What's happening why am I here does this work do I look stupid what's happening am I doing it wrong can I ever get better you know all of that stuff is a protective part that doesn't want me to just drop down in and feel the bad place and it's all popping up and roiling and sometimes you can bleed that off with a resource spot and a resource uh thigh and then you can go in and do processing on an activation spot. That's one technique that I use a lot.
如果有人在思考或冷静下来方面有困难，可以用资源侧和资源点来消除焦虑。然后你转向激活眼，找到激活点，尝试以那种方式进入。现在我能够进行处理了，因为我的思绪不再翻腾，不再想“这是什么？我为什么在这里？这管用吗？我看起来很蠢吗？发生了什么？我做错了吗？我能好起来吗？”你知道，所有这些都是一种保护机制，它不想让我沉下去感受那个糟糕的地方，所有这些想法都在涌现和翻腾。有时你可以用资源点和资源眼来消除这些干扰，然后你就可以进入并对激活点进行处理。这是我经常使用的一种技术。
Another one that I think doesn't get talked about enough is metaphor. The bottom part of our brain, when cognition during brain spotting, cognition is off and the prefrontal cortex is not terribly active and really deep processing, you're very deep in the mid and the subcortical brain. It's this place where like emotion is tied to physical expressions of emotion so it's very pure emotion and then where that emotion is in your body and what it's doing and kind of the way that jung said that the bottom levels of the
我认为另一个没有被充分讨论的方法是隐喻。我们大脑的底层，在脑点定位期间，认知功能是关闭的，前额叶皮层并不太活跃，在进行深度处理时，你处于中脑和皮层下脑的深处。这是一个将情感与情感的身体表达联系起来的地方，所以它是非常纯粹的情感，以及这种情感在身体的什么位置，它在做什么，以及荣格所说的底层水平的方式。
brain and its language was metaphor it wasn't language and i think that we respond and that you know dream is is like that you know, dream is like that, you know. Dream is kind of when the ego or consciousness is turned off and you're making, you know, essentially a symbol of how you feel or a symbol of this thing that your unconscious is chewing on because you don't have the ability to think about it literally. You know, when you're trying to help somebody feel something, because that's the key to going into brain spotting and most kinds of effective therapy is, can I make you stop thinking about this, analyzing it, intellectualizing it and just feel it? Metaphor is helpful, you know, and not everyone's going to respond to that. Definitely be open. You know, none of this is saying that the uncertainty principle of, you know, David Grand and the trainings is wrong, but you can be open to all of that and still say, you know, from in your head, maybe, you know, most people this happens.
大脑及其语言是隐喻，而不是语言。我认为我们会有反应，你知道，梦就是那样的。梦是在自我或意识关闭时，你本质上是在为你感受到的东西或你的潜意识正在咀嚼的东西制造一个符号，因为你没有能力从字面上思考它。你知道，当你试图帮助某人感受某事时，因为这是进入脑点定位和大多数有效疗法的关键，我能让你停止思考、分析、理智化，而只是去感受它吗？隐喻是有帮助的，并不是每个人都会对此有反应。一定要保持开放。这并不是说大卫·格兰（David Grand）和培训中的不确定性原则是错误的，但你可以对所有这些保持开放，同时在心里想，也许大多数人会发生这种情况。
So if this doesn't work, I'm going to try this. I mean, I don't think that's violating the uncertainty principle. I think that's trying things until something works. You know, sitting with the uncertainty of everybody is different. I'm not going to do the same thing for everybody. But some people think in a metaphorical language, and it helps them feel so you may have a strong thinker type that's like, No, maybe this is when I was two. I don't know. It can't be when I was two, because I had a good life then. And, you know, my back hurts sometimes, but not right now. And you're like, Okay, just feel the back, though. No,
所以如果这个方法不管用，我会尝试那个。我不认为这违反了不确定性原则。我认为这是在尝试各种方法，直到找到有效的方法。坐在那里面对每个人都不同的不确定性。我不会对每个人都做同样的事情。但有些人用隐喻语言思考，这有助于他们感受。所以你可能会遇到一个强思考型的人，他说：“不，也许这是我两岁时的事。我不知道。不可能是两岁时的事，因为那时我过得很好。而且，我的背有时会疼，但现在不疼。”你会说：“好吧，但请感受一下背部。”不，
no, no. And you just see them them every time you suggest the body they zing back up into their head you know maybe say okay when you're sitting with your neck you said you felt tired what is that tired like you know do you feel like you're just a mountain climber that's climbing up a mountain and you have to achieve this great thing and you're worried that you can't you know is it more of like a fear of not being able to do it or do you just feel like you were in the middle of the perfect storm on a sailboat and waves are smashing and it's, you're fighting and fighting, but it's completely hopeless. You just, you're hopeless. You cannot, you cannot win because you're, you're go up in a sailboat against an Eflin tornado and you're trying so hard, but deep down, you just don't
不，不。每次你提到身体，他们就会回到脑子里。也许你可以说：“好吧，当你关注脖子时，你说你感到累，那种累是什么样的？你感觉自己就像一个正在爬山的登山者，必须完成这件伟大的事情，而你担心自己做不到吗？这更像是一种无法完成的恐惧，还是你感觉自己就像在帆船上遇到了完美的风暴，海浪在拍打，你在战斗，但完全没有希望？你只是感到绝望。你不可能赢，因为你正驾驶着帆船对抗龙卷风，你非常努力，但在内心深处，你只是不
really feel like you could do it. Or, you know, is it, um, you know, an exhaustion, like you just can't even muster up any muscles, you just want to turn into slime and drip through the floor right here, okay? So, like, I didn't just ask a thinker type there, hey, do you feel hopeless or do you feel afraid of not accomplishing something or do you just feel exhausted, right? I'm offering them into a felt experience of being tired to really figure out what that means and where that is in their body. That isn't saying, what do you feel? Where is it in your body? Or just feel, you know, I'm trying to offer them a gateway into that experience. And I think that you have to keep trying something until something works.
真的觉得你能做到。或者，这是一种精疲力竭，就像你甚至无法调动任何肌肉，只想变成粘液从地板上滴下去，好吗？所以，我刚才并没有问一个思考型的人“你感到绝望吗？还是害怕无法完成某事？或者只是感到精疲力竭？”我是在引导他们进入一种疲惫的身体体验，以真正弄清楚这意味着什么以及它在身体的什么位置。这并不是说“你感觉到了什么？它在身体的什么位置？”或者只是“去感受”，我是在试图为他们提供进入那种体验的途径。我认为你必须不断尝试，直到找到有效的方法。
And the people that I do hear from online, it's where the clinician is just doing the same thing. And I have total respect for the uncertainty principle and the idea of dual attunement that brain spotting uses a lot, that it's two people together feeling something. But you're not sitting with dual attunement if you're not watching the eye. You're not sitting with dual attunement if you're not noticing the way somebody thinks. You're not sitting with dual attunement unless you're really paying attention to things about them they may not notice. Instead of just asking them, what do you feel? What do you feel? You need to realize what they feel, you know? Sometimes you'll be able to realize that better than the patient and then help
我在网上听到的人们反馈说，临床医生只是在做同样的事情。我完全尊重不确定性原则和脑点定位中经常使用的双重调谐（dual attunement）理念，即两个人在一起感受某事。但如果你不观察眼睛，你就不是在进行双重调谐。如果你不注意某人的思考方式，你就不是在进行双重调谐。除非你真正关注他们可能没有注意到的事情，否则你不是在进行双重调谐。与其只是问他们“你感觉到了什么？”，你需要意识到他们的感受。有时你能比患者更好地意识到这一点，然后帮助
them experience that too. That's dual attunement, okay? The uncertainty principle is not doing the same thing every time. It's sitting with the uncertainty of, yeah, let's see what comes up, but this doesn't seem to work. So let's try something else, you know? And sometimes I think people take the uncertainty principle language to mean like, oh, you just talk about the uncertainty principle and say, well, we have no idea what's going to come up. But no, I think what it means is that like you keep trying new things and because you need to be able to sit with your own uncertainty to not have a script, to not have a formula, to be innovative, to be uncertain, to have doubt and to innovate. And a lot of times I hear clinicians like talking about the uncertainty principle, like in, you know, groups or something or online. You know, there's some things, but then it doesn't really seem like they are willing to let themselves sit in uncertainty. They just want to talk about uncertainty. So this stuff is not a
他们也体验到这一点。这就是双重调谐。不确定性原则不是每次都做同样的事情。它是坐在不确定性中，说“好吧，看看会出现什么”，但如果这似乎不起作用，那就尝试别的方法。有时我认为人们把不确定性原则的语言理解为“哦，你只是谈论不确定性，说我们不知道会发生什么”。但我不这么认为，我认为它的意思是你要不断尝试新事物，因为你需要能够面对自己的不确定性，不依赖脚本，不依赖公式，要创新，要不确定，要有怀疑并进行创新。很多时候，我听到临床医生在小组或网上谈论不确定性原则，但他们似乎并不愿意让自己处于不确定性中。他们只是想谈论不确定性。所以这些并不是对
criticism of the way brain spotting works. It's a different perspective and it's, you know, a way of thinking about it differently. So hopefully we can get to a different place with our patients. So, yeah, I mean, and again, I don't want it to sound like I'm criticizing the brain spotting training. I think that a lot of times you know You're playing the telephone game with David writes a thing with his students which gets written down which trained this person trained that person And maybe we just lose the spirit of it. He's I'm sure that he's a great clinician They're all the people doing the trainings or or wonderful clinicians when you're in the room with them They're probably doing great work
脑点定位工作方式的批评。这是一种不同的视角，是一种不同的思考方式。所以希望我们能与患者达到一个不同的境界。所以，是的，我不想听起来像是在批评脑点定位培训。我认为很多时候，你在玩传话游戏，大卫写了一些东西给他的学生，学生写下来，然后培训了这个人，那个人又培训了别人，也许我们只是失去了它的精神。我相信他是一位伟大的临床医生，所有进行培训的人都是很棒的临床医生，当你和他们在一起时，他们可能正在做伟大的工作。
But I do hear this stuff over and over and over people call and they say I don't think spawning works. That's not good for the profession. Like it's not good for the modality. So it's important for people to be able to try and help people go into processing if they're having a hard time by putting them in the subcortical brain. What are you smelling? What are you tasting? What are you feeling? How does your body want to move? Where's the tension? What does it feel like? Not just hot, the tension? What does it feel like? Not just hot, cold, tight. Does it feel like TV static? Does it feel like the color green?
但我确实一遍又一遍地听到这些事情，人们打电话说“我不认为脑点定位有效”。这对这个行业来说不是好事。这对这种疗法来说不是好事。所以，如果人们在进入皮层下脑时遇到困难，能够尝试帮助他们进入处理状态是很重要的。你在闻什么？你在尝什么？你在感受什么？你的身体想怎么动？紧张在哪里？感觉是什么样的？不仅仅是热、冷、紧。感觉像电视静电吗？感觉像绿色吗？
Like make room for anything. What do you feel outside your body? Do you feel heavier than the room, lighter than the room? You're saying that your chest feels heavy. Is it heavy like pushing down? Is it heavy like you're struggling to hold it up and your legs are tight? Is it heavy like it's pulling you to the floor or pushing down on your chest? All those questions help people go, what? I hadn't
为任何事情留出空间。你在身体之外感受到了什么？你感觉比房间重还是轻？你说你的胸部感觉沉重。是像向下压一样沉重吗？还是像你在努力支撑它，腿部紧绷一样沉重？是像把你拉向地板，还是压在你的胸口上？所有这些问题都能帮助人们说“什么？我还没
thought about that. And then they're experiencing more and it is your job to help them learn to think this way so that they can process this stuff. And the language of brain spawning is really like the training sits based, I'm guessing, I haven't asked David Graham this, but it looks like he's very into existentialism and chaos theory, which, if you've read the Jurassic Park book way back when, it's the little propeller thing that Michael Crichton threw in there to give it some spiritual thematic depth. But this idea that, like, we can never know anything, that everything is just so complicated that one change can make this butterfly effect, and, you know, I'm not an expert on any of that. I'm a little bit more mystical, like I'm using more Jungian language
想到过这一点。”然后他们体验到了更多，帮助他们学会这样思考是你的工作，这样他们才能处理这些东西。脑点定位的语言确实像培训的基础，我猜，我没有问过大卫·格兰，但他看起来非常热衷于存在主义和混沌理论。如果你读过很久以前的《侏罗纪公园》那本书，迈克尔·克莱顿在里面加入了一个小螺旋桨装置，赋予它一些精神主题深度。但这种观点认为，我们永远无法知道任何事情，一切都太复杂了，一个改变就能产生蝴蝶效应。我不是这方面的专家。我更神秘一点，我使用了更多的荣格语言，
about like going down to face the places underneath your life that at the time you didn't think you could survive. But when you go back into it to face them, that you can't take everything you know with you, you can't take the ego with you. When you go back in, you might be two or you might be four and you don't have the protection of your intellect and all the things that you know now. Neither one of those is right or wrong. But I think in the existential kind of chaos theory language that he's using when he writes those trainings about like that you want to push people
关于去面对你生命中那些你当时认为无法幸存的地方。但当你回到那里去面对它们时，你不能带走你所知道的一切，你不能带走自我。当你回去时，你可能两岁或四岁，你没有你的智力和你现在所知道的一切的保护。这两者都没有对错之分。但我认为在他编写那些培训时使用的存在主义混沌理论语言中，关于你想要推动人们，
and you want the provider needs to just be open to anything happening absolutely be open to anything happening but if nothing is happening that's not being open if you're doing the same thing over and over and over again and the person is not going into processing or if you're trying to get somebody to process that's not being open another thing that I do which is probably a little bit against the rules as I said you know the glasses have an activation spot and they also have and there's an activation eye and there's also an activation spot, right? Well, sometimes when somebody is just telling me I can see the spot, but they're not considering it, they're like, I don't feel anything. This doesn't work. You know, it's a very resistant person who
并且提供者需要对发生的任何事情保持开放。绝对要对发生的任何事情保持开放，但如果什么都没发生，那就不叫开放。如果你一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，而那个人没有进入处理状态，或者如果你试图让某人处理，那就不叫开放。我做的另一件事可能有点违反规则，正如我所说，眼镜有一个激活点，还有一个激活眼，还有一个激活点，对吧？好吧，有时当某人只是告诉我我能看到那个点，但他们没有在考虑它，他们说“我什么都没感觉到，这不管用”。你知道，这是一个非常抗拒的人，
needs to be sold on this because it is weird. I didn't believe this worked until I did it. I mean, you know, you're, you're fine to doubt it. You know, there's, I can see them feeling a little bit, but they're moving their head. I will put the activation glass on and then I will hit an activation spot, which makes the little trauma response too strong, right? I'm not saying just dive in and do this to somebody, okay? But there are people who have needed help feeling that this is a real thing and they need help validating this themselves and I'll put that on for just a second and then whoa okay just a second like when I've turned that spot up to 11 and you're really strongly feeling that then that means that you're able to accept that it's real we're not fighting about
需要被说服，因为这很奇怪。直到我亲自尝试之前，我也不相信这管用。我的意思是，你可以怀疑它。我知道，我能看到他们感觉到了一点，但他们在移动头部。我会戴上激活眼镜，然后击中一个激活点，这会让创伤反应变得太强烈，对吧？我不是说直接跳进去对某人做这件事，好吗？但有些人需要帮助才能感觉到这是一件真实的事情，他们需要帮助来验证这一点，我会戴上它一秒钟，然后“哇，好吧，就一秒钟”。就像当我把那个点调到11级，你真的强烈地感受到了，那就意味着你能够接受它是真实的，我们不再争论
whether or not this works anymore because you just felt it and then okay that looks like it's a little bit too strong is that a little bit too strong well then let's take the glasses off and do it slower maybe we need to use the resource glasses but we're no longer you know debating if it's real or not you've already felt it you understand that it's working and now we're rolling um i don't do that with everybody usually the activation i activation spotting is when somebody's processed it so much and we're really trying to squeeze the limit and get everything up out of the spot it's already come down so much what the distress was and we're just trying to get the last little bit sometimes i'll do that i don't recommend processing that way i'm not saying that you just
这是否管用了，因为你已经感受到了。然后“好吧，那看起来有点太强烈了，是吗？”那我们就摘下眼镜，慢一点做。也许我们需要使用资源眼镜，但我们不再争论它是否真实，你已经感受到了，你明白它在起作用，现在我们开始了。我不是对每个人都这样做。通常，激活眼激活点定位是在某人已经处理了很多，我们真的在试图挤压极限，把那个点里的所有东西都弄出来，痛苦已经减轻了很多，我们只是在试图得到最后一点。有时我会这样做，我不建议那样处理。我不是说你只是
turn it up to 11 use the activation spot with the activation glasses and then you know make somebody just process way too much that's just much. But if somebody's having a really hard time feeling it or admitting to themselves that this eye position actually is activating a trauma, sometimes that's a good way to sell this procedure because they'll immediately feel it. And then I think that will lead them more into feeling and more into trusting you in the process. And then you can follow the comment and see where it goes. So I don't know if y'all have questions or anything, let me know. But those are the things that if you're a therapist or if you're a client, you may want to think about doing or asking your therapist for. Because I just, I don't know,
把它调到11级，使用带有激活眼镜的激活点，然后让某人处理得太多，那太多了。但如果某人很难感受到它，或者很难向自己承认这个眼睛位置实际上正在激活创伤，有时这是一个推销这个程序的好方法，因为他们会立即感觉到它。然后我认为这会引导他们更多地去感受，更多地信任这个过程。然后你可以跟随评论，看看它会走向何方。所以我不知道你们是否有问题，请告诉我。但如果你是一名治疗师，或者如果你是一名客户，这些是你可能想要考虑做的事情，或者向你的治疗师询问的事情。因为我只是，我不知道，
I've got a lot of brain spotting videos and podcasts on the internet and I get phone calls on our voicemail from people who are out of state, out of the country sometimes, and all the time that I hear that the brain spotting is not working and they're asking me, how do I get this to work? Because they're not doing what you say you do on there. What they're describing is somebody who's just holding the pointer, encouraging the patient to feel while the patient's not feeling. I mean, that's too structured. The person is getting upset there. You need to be a little bit more open and do some different things or suggest to your therapist. I mean, I see a brain spotting therapist and I said, hey, I bounced the pointer this way. I'm having a really hard time going into processing. Could you try and do this? And she was open to it. She did it with me. It worked great.
我在互联网上有很多脑点定位的视频和播客，我会在语音信箱里接到来自州外，有时是国外的电话，我一直听到脑点定位不起作用，他们问我，我该怎么让它起作用？因为他们没有做你在上面说的那样。他们描述的是一个只是拿着指针，鼓励病人去感受，而病人并没有在感受的人。我的意思是，那太结构化了。那个人在那里感到不安。你需要更开放一点，做一些不同的事情，或者向你的治疗师建议。我去看了一位脑点定位治疗师，我说“嘿，我这样弹动指针。我在进入处理状态方面遇到了很大困难。你能试着这样做吗？”她对此很开放。她和我一起做了。效果很好。
So that would be some of the biggest barriers I see to when brain spotting does not work. I do think the process works, but I don't think that it works for everybody. And when it doesn't work, the majority of the time, what I see is that the clinician is just having a hard time getting the person into processing because they took away from the training that as long as they just wait it out, the person will just start to process eventually. They don't have to move the pointer. They don't have to change what they're saying.
所以这就是我看到的脑点定位不起作用时最大的障碍。我确实认为这个过程是有效的，但我不认为它对每个人都有效。当它不起作用时，大多数时候，我看到的是临床医生在让病人进入处理状态方面遇到了困难，因为他们从培训中得到的结论是，只要他们等待，病人最终就会开始处理。他们不需要移动指针。他们不需要改变他们说的话。
They just encourage you to feel and ask you if you feel what, where. And then eventually after session number 30, you'll just start going. I don't think that's right. One, that's just too much time. Most people are going to leave. And then two, I don't think that by doing the same thing, you get a different result. So I hope that that was helpful and I will see you in brain spotting. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们只是鼓励你感受，并问你感受到了什么，在哪里。然后最终在第30次疗程后，你就会开始进入状态。我不认为那是对的。第一，那花费的时间太多了。大多数人会离开。第二，我不认为通过做同样的事情，你能得到不同的结果。所以我希望这很有帮助，我们会在脑点定位中再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。